I've been here since I was 8 in school
it teaches to be patriotic I thought I
was part of the country and I feel
betrayed
the first thing that immediately was
asked since it was Border Patrol they
were like you guys have papers and my
uncle my aunt and my mother didn't so
all three of them were taken in they got
stopped for speeding or something and
he's in documented and they took him in
like they detained him we know it just a
little kid
like my family was taken away from me me
and my dad were able to see her
handcuffed and being put into this band
where they were taking a lot of people
who had order of deportation so we had
plans that my mom would wait until
Monday to speak to our lawyer but it was
Sunday morning when she called us and
she was in Nogales Mexico and so she was
already deported 15 officers from ice
got up from the cars surrounded my dad
screaming to stay where he was and then
they started arresting him putting the
handcuffs on I was in the kitchen I saw
everything they just took my dad my mom
she's very very talkative me my brother
my dad are all very serious quiet
we obviously felt like an energy was
missing and that was my mom's energy
he was the biggest source of income in
our house he was also the life of the
house he was best friends to my sister
he was best friend to me he was a the
one who protected you really noticed
like the little things that he would do
for us like for example I would always
ask him help her homework
I was just 12 and I was like going
through big changes for me and I really
needed my mom and like all these things
were happening to me and I'm like I
don't know what to do I don't know I
need my mom my mom she's undocumented
it's a constant fear I always like I'm
scared that she might not come home one
day because she works out like all
around Arizona so they could just one
day they could just be stopped and
because of that she could be detained
the fear is always in me especially for
my dad mm oh God
like like ever since that happened and
it's like it can happen to anyone
we been living here for a long time and
we want to feel the part even more part
of this country have the American dream
him and my mom sacrificed basically all
of their lives and that they had in
Mexico when we came to the u.s. they
left their families they live the
friends just to give us a future
my older sister she's in college or not
USC and like my older brother's actually
going to NYU they think they get a slice
the American dreams through us it's my
hope I mean I'm gonna go to college I'm
gonna get my degree in aerospace
engineering be someone in life make my
family proud of me that's for sure